so we begin the week with something
positive for a change this only happens
about once a year on this show so soak
it in while you can cbs new news aired a
report on friday about some unique
measures being taken at a high school in
louisiana to stop the violence and chaos
that had been plaguing the campus
southwood high school in shreveport
began uh the year in september with
multiple major bras brawls and and
fights and everything between between
students and over the course of just
three days over 20 kids were arrested
for assault and other charges
and that's when as the cbs report tells
us
the dads of the community decided to do
something about it let's listen
nobody here has a degree in school
counseling
no majors in criminal justice no no your
qualifications are fair
we decided the best people who can take
care of our kids or who for us what we
do so michael lafitte started dads on
duty we're out doing what we do for our
babies a group of about 40 southwood
dads who now hang out at the school in
shifts that's gold today any negative
energy that enters the building has to
run a gauntlet of good parenting what's
going on buddy you're moving fast i like
that horse i immediately felt a form of
safety we stopped fighting people
started going to class how could that be
you ever heard of a look a look dads
have the power to do that yes
not many people know it but yes
let's go let's go but it's not just the
firm stares and stern warnings let's
make it to class my son it's also the
dad jokes
they just make funny jokes like oh hey
your student's untied but it's really
not untied
they hate it they're so embarrassed by
it
and it's that perfect mix of tough love
and gentle ribbing that dads do so well
that has helped transform this school
the school has really just been like
happy and you can feel it
which is why the dads plan to keep
coming to southwood indefinitely because
not everybody has a father a father
figure at home or a male period in their
life so just to be here
makes a big difference do you think you
stumbled onto something here
absolutely absolutely
have you stumbled onto something he asks
yes they've stumbled onto something
called fatherhood
see
you know i watch something like this and
i want to celebrate it i do celebrate it
dad's getting involved taking
charge of their children and their
communities
it's a beautiful sight to behold
and yet i'm frustrated at the same time
that so many in our culture especially
those who control the narrative
can't connect the dots or refuse to
connect them
i mean the media will tell us
heartwarming stories like this and
they'll rightfully applaud the men
who've stepped up
then they'll write the whole thing off
as a gimmick an aberration or at best as
something isolated
sure lots of problems can be fixed when
dads get involved but only at school and
only when they're wearing matching
t-shirts and only when they give
themselves a clever name like dad's on
duty
then they'll go back to supporting
organizations like blm which has the
explicit goal of destroying the nuclear
family
and they'll go back to pretending that
men and women are interchangeable and
identical
and they'll go back to celebrating
single motherhood as the pinnacle of
parenting excellence
and they'll go back to calling you
racist if you suggest that many of the
problems about in the black community
stem from the scarcity of fathers in the
home
see this this dad's on duty thing is
then relegated to a cute little human
interest story a nice two-minute
video that can go viral on twitter the
broader societal implications are
ignored
because they in the media they're not
they're not going to stop to ask
you know why this school experienced
a seemingly miraculous change simply by
the physical presence
of firm and attentive men on school
grounds
this this cognitive dissonance goes
beyond the media they're the ones
driving it purposefully but there are a
lot of normal people in our society who
struggle with this same disconnect
i couldn't help but notice lots of the
accounts with blm in their bio
we're sharing this video apparently not
realizing
that the content of the video directly
contradicts and flies in the face of the
stated goals of the organization they
pledge allegiance to
but if we're able to somehow lift our
heads above this
swirl of contradictions we'll see that
the dads in shreveport
are not some anomalous case nor are they
living in a cultural vacuum
this is this is true universally
children need fathers preferably their
own fathers and if they can't have their
own fathers either because he's dead
or worse he has chosen to abandon them
then they need male leadership somewhere
else
a child who grows up with no male
leadership at all
a child who is raised only by women this
is a lot of kids
will be severely disabled
psychologically emotionally and
spiritually
that's not because the female influence
is bad for a child but because the
female influence is only one half of the
complete picture it's one half of the
recipe
a child can survive physically on half
but he'll be
deeply malnourished
so what is it that dads bring to the
table why why can't they be so easily
replaced why do why do they leave an
enormous hole behind when they abandon
their posts
well we see it in the clip that was just
played
for one thing dads are a more imposing
and formidable presence
and they exud they exude that aura
naturally
you know kids are almost always better
behaved when dad is around it's not
because they don't respect mom but
because they see mom as a gentler and
more empathetic presence
it's crucial that they have such a
presence in their lives but there's a
flip side to every coin especially in
parenting and the flip side in this case
is that they think they can get away
with more they think they can be a
little bit looser they can push more
boundaries with mom
unless dad is there but a good dad is
not just stern he's he's not solely an
authority figure dads can be playful and
irreverent in a unique sort of way again
moms have that role as well but it
manifests in different ways
and then of course there's the most
important dad contribution or one of the
most important contributions
for a boy specifically dad is around
to show him how to be a man 95 percent
of this job has to be done through
demonstration not lecturing
and as a boy grows older he might forget
almost everything his dad ever told him
but he won't forget the example that was
set for better or worse
the boys at that school in shreveport
most of them
have probably never had a man around to
show them how men are supposed to
conduct themselves
millions of boys are being raised in
this way on a sort of island and it
becomes very much a lord of the flies
situation
which becomes all the more pronounced in
urban schools because these are boys who
are walking a path to manhood
with no man walking in front of them no
footsteps to follow no guidance of any
kind
the result then
is chaos violence despair
almost every bad thing we see in society
drug abuse suicide
uh
you know
crime violent crime all of it
stems back largely to this issue
and we really have no right to expect
any other result
when we remove male leadership from
society
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated